oK we've got today kind of like a big
ketchup day going to do a bunch of
different stories get everybody caught
up hopefully some folks tuned out from
everything going on over the weekend I
know I tried to let's get caught back up
and then tomorrow we're going to have
some deeper dives into some more some
more some more deeper dives into some
particular elements as I like to call
them of what's going on with the virus
or response the Democratic primary so
let's get right into it
Donald Trump has previously floated the
idea of being open by Easter as a
country clearly because medical experts
have gotten to him he has canceled that
Donald Trump announced yesterday during
a press briefing which we covered live
it was outside the White House that we
will be closed until April 30 abiding by
those guidelines the social distancing
guidelines and of course this is sort of
the case because there are lots of
states that are doing very little so far
but for the states and the people who
have been distancing closing
non-essential businesses etc it's going
to be another thirty two days from today
until we might be able to start opening
things up this is both depressing and
frustrating but not surprising and
clearly necessary that's the reality
it's depressing and necessary in order
to continue fighting the virus here is
Donald Trump yesterday announcing this
the modeling estimates that the peak in
death rate is likely to hit in two weeks
so I'll say it again the peak the
highest point of death rates
remember this is likely to hit in two
weeks nothing would be worse than
declaring victory before the victory is
won that would be the greatest loss of
all therefore the next two weeks and
during this period it's very important
that every one strongly follow the
guidelines have to follow the guidelines
that our great vice president holds up a
lot he's holding that up a lot he
believes in it so strongly the better
you do the faster this whole nightmare
will end
therefore we will be extending our
guidelines to April 30th to slow the
spread and Donald Trump is 100% correct
he's a liar he's a bad president he's
incompetent he cares more about his own
ratings as we will talk about then the
death toll but this is the right
decision and I'll talk to you a little
bit about the peak and the data but when
he said it I simultaneously sort of
experienced dread and relief the numbers
are exploding the health care system is
rapidly getting closer and closer to
being overwhelmed which increases the
death rate as we've tragically seen in
other countries including Italy and I'm
struggling with it I mean my nature is
to be out all the time to be in cafes to
be with friends to be at the gym to be
with family I'm doing none of it I've
cancelled multiple trips major show
appearances may be getting cancelled but
I've got electricity I'm not sick with
the virus for the time being and
hopefully most of us won't be we will be
better off in the long run and this is
the right decision now as far as the
numbers and the peak there is very good
data there's a model that every day is
fine-tuned with the latest data from dr.
Christopher Murray professor of Health
metrics sciences medical doctor
professor really good study with
confidence intervals about this his
estimate is that nationally April 15th
will be the peak date that means a 15
more days 15 more full days from today
now this is really really important to
understand because some people here
April 15 they think great that's when
it's all wide open others think no that
can't possibly be it seems too soon the
peak simply means we get to the top not
that we necessarily come down from it
and the doctor expects that the peak
will last a few days right around 2,200
deaths per day that's going to be a
cluster of about six days April 14th to
19th during those six days he estimates
somewhere between 12 and 13 thousand
people will die in total and then it
will start to decline 2,100 people will
die
I then you know 2050 so if we are 15
days to the peak and the peak will last
five or six days that means in 15 plus
five plus another 15 days meaning 35
more days we'd be back to a day like
today if you consider the upswing and
then the downswing we're roughly six to
eight hundred people will die we're not
sure yet of the exact numbers today and
in fact the decline from the peak may be
more spread out it may be a more gradual
decline than the ascent to the peak so
this is with a confidence interval so
when you look at the graphic you see the
dotted line which says for example you
know 2271 deaths on April 15th but it
could be as few as 1180 that day it
could be as many as 3500 that's the
range with 2271 being the number in
between so that's what it's looking like
now and under this estimate the total
deaths would be about 82,000 in the US
for this cycle of the virus this is
important to understand this model
doesn't look at the fact that these
pandemics will often have two or three
peaks and the next one may come in the
fall
this is 82,000 deaths through the end of
the summer again that's with a
confidence interval could be as low as
39,000 could be as high as a hundred and
forty 2000 based on the data we have
right now the better we do with social
distancing the lower the number is and
someday things will start to get back to
normal but it's going to be months and
you know somebody said to me over the
weekend these things have a beginning a
middle and an end we are past the
beginning we are definitely in the
middle of this right now hopefully from
mid april on will start to move from the
middle to the end at least of phase one
and it's going to be a long fight all we
can do is take a day by day and that's
what I'm trying to do I want to give a
quick shout-out to one of our sponsors
VIN Chara watches they're giving my
audience 15% off your entire order when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch
maybe you don't usually wear a watch and
you've been
thinking about looking for one to
elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have
check out VIN chair oh it's an American
company all of their watches are built
in small batches from high-end materials
they look amazing and they look like
something you'd spend a lot of money on
but ever even chair Oh watch ranges from
a hundred and fifty to three hundred
dollars I went on their website and
picked out the Kyros in white and silver
really love the look the combination of
the white face and the beige band really
love this one they also sent me the
Kyros limited release gold reserve set
totally different style this one would
make a fantastic gift for a couple
people I can think of in my family any
time you see me wearing a watch on the
show I'm wearing a van share o watch go
through their collection I know you'll
find something you like and you'll get
15% off when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch